but i'm curious man because like you've
obviously done records with some of the
biggest artists in the world
and like with the funk volume thing
imploding and then you having to kind of
figure this out for yourself
moving forward i'm sure you could have
at that point in time probably gotten a
deal if you wanted one
and and did the major label thing which
would have been new to you kind of right
but you decided to kind of just hunker
down and and stick to the independent
[ __ ]
like why why that as opposed to you know
trying to go get a deal with atlantic or
whoever the [ __ ]
yeah because i i like i don't have
sometimes i feel like i don't have the
same desires as some of these other
artists like
i don't really want it all too fast uh
getting it all too fast kind of makes me
nervous
i grew up with the bare minimum so i
feel like i know how to maneuver off of
what feels to me like a lot right now
even in the independent game i feel like
the love
the traveling to being able to create
the music it's what i want to do
being able to work with different
artists and like having a range
a wide range of like um sounds that i
can tap in with different people and i
just feel like this is what i wanted
you know it don't it's not as glamorous
from the outside looking in but you know
i make good money i own my masters
you know i'm intact with my soul my
spirit you know
and i do what i want you know i can move
at my own pace like if something is
if something don't feel right i could
pull the plug you know but i can also
take chances you know i can like i like
being in control of when i can
when i want to like maybe take a chance
go out on the edge a little bit
and just that kind of like slow-paced
grind so i've always been
i guess like content bro with being
independent and watching it grow
slowly and just every year is something
new whether it's the shrines getting
more shrines or it's the store
and people coming out to the store i
just see like if you just slowly keep
pushing at something
she would just keep unfolding you know i
was gonna say like um
everyone has their own uh successes and
always
we look at this music industry and it's
so superficial right
it's like people will look at you and be
like ah
man like well you ain't you ain't doing
what this person's doing and this
person's doing but
i think success for everyone and and
happiness is subjective
right you don't have absolutely for a
fact and if you think about it a lot of
the stuff with some of these
you know some artists that are signed
you know
it don't when the curtain closed it it
looked a lot different backstage than it
looks in front of stage you know yeah
so it's it's like whatever you feel
comfortable with do you
always sometimes those people don't have
the right control
something they a lot of times they don't
have the money you know you're taking
money you owe people a lot of money you
know the stakes are higher you know so
everybody's in your business trying to
tell you what to do and what not to do
and it just depends on how
you want to do this music thing you know
the cool [ __ ] is like
you able to do it it's big enough the
pool is big enough for people to do it
every which way to get to it
and at the end of the day you know it's
your legacy you leave him behind
and how many people you're gonna have
involved with it